[upbeat relaxing music]
What's your name?
Just the Jew I guess.
- Nice to meet you, Moshe.
What are you doing
at the psychedelic conference.
- I'm a psychedelic researcher.
- When did you first realize
that tripping balls
would be your life's work?
Obviously, you already
kinda look like a dude
that is pre-ready to...
- Yeah.
- Think psychedelics will help.
- Thank you.
- Have you ever had
actual experience
of a psychedelic
healing you from something?
- Yes, I have.
I've been suffering
from Shingles.
Went down to the jungle...
[audience laughing]
And I had
an Ayahuasca experience.
I'm getting completely cured.
- Do they do anything with, um--
Can you shut the cameras off?
Do they do anything with,
uh, erectile stuff? Like--
- [laughs]
- Did you have the, like,
barbarian collar pre-Ayahuasca
or is this a new identity?
- You mean this here?
- Were you already
a bit of a hippy beforehand?
- No, dear.
I wasn't a hippy, actually.
- No?
- I was a police officer.
- No!
- I found 45-50% of people
communicate with some
non-human entity
when they smoke salvia.
- So where you doing the study?
Like some learning annex?
Like Hippy Dippy University?
- Oh, it's at Harvard.
- Harvard what?
- These human beings--
or protohumans,
have these ineffable
mysterious experiences...
That attempt to reach
and communicate...
There's a boundary
dissolution...
Ancient human culture
had already...
Improving the cohesion
of the tribal unit...
Cosmic portrait of the world.
- Okay, that was great.
Could you just repeat everything
that you said?
- Yes.
- Why are psychedelics
important?
Why shouldn't they be taboo?
- Because they're incredibly
valuable tools
to heal the human psyche.
So to get down there
and open it up and shake it out.
- Have you heard
of a Shake Weight?
- No.
- It's one where you just
shake it and it's a weight.
- Yeah?
- I don't know if it works,
but...
- That's really what
psychedelics do to the psyche.
- Oh, it's like a Shake Weight
for your brain?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- I have a hypnogogic
light machine.
Some people have
a psychedelic journey/
- So this is drugs
without drugs.
- Yeah.
Go ahead. Watch your head.
Okay, any history of seizures?
- No.
- Okay,
all right, good thing.
[funky music]
♪ ♪
- Tripping balls...
[echoing] Tripping balls...
[indistinct distorted voices]
[hawk cries]
- Seagulls...
[echoing] Seagulls...
- [distorted] Oh, wow.
- [distorted] It's like
a Shake Weight for your brain.
- [distorted]
I was a police officer.
- [distorted] No!
Cookie Monster...[growling]
♪ ♪
[music stops]
[indistinct chattering]
[audience laughing]
♪ ♪
[hawk cries]